up to twenty thousand dollars in debt
cancellation to pell grant recipients
with loans held by the department of
education
and ten thousand dollars in debt
cancellation to non-pell grant
recipients
this relief is targeted it will only go
to borrowers whose income is less than
125 thousand dollars for an individual
or 250 000
for a household
meaning that the relief will go to those
who need it most
third the administration is proposing
critical reforms
to the income driven repayment plan that
will ensure that current and future
borrowers will have much smaller and
more manageable monthly payments
this new plan protects more low-income
borrowers from making any payments and
caps monthly payments for undergraduate
loans at five percent
of a borrower's discretionary income
meaning after essentials like rent and
food
that is half the rate that people
currently pay today
and borrowers making roughly the
equivalent of fifteen dollars uh the
minimum wage where that applies
won't have to make any payments at all
under this plan
these changes will reduce the average
annual student loan repayment by a
thousand dollars a year
fourth thanks to temporary changes that
the department of education has made to
the public service loan forgiveness
program
if you have worked in public service for
example as a teacher
a government employee a military service
member
for 10 years
even if those years were not consecutive
you are eligible to have all of your
federal student loans cancelled
the department of education is working
to make these changes permanent
but in the meantime
more than a hundred and seventy five
thousand people just in the last year
have taken advantage of these temporary
changes and have had more than ten
billion
dollars in loans forgiven
so my message to everybody today is if
you currently or previously have worked
in public service
go now to
pslf.gov p s l f dot gov
to take advantage of this program but
you must do so before october thirty
first
finally the department of education is
announcing new actions to hold
accountable colleges that have
contributed to the student debt crisis
including by publishing an annual watch
list
of the programs with the worst debt
levels
in the country and requesting
improvement plans from the worst actors
these actions build on steps the
president has already taken
to reduce the need to borrow
including by signing the largest
increase to the maximum pell grant in
over a decade and providing nearly 40
billion dollars to colleges and
universities through the american rescue
plan
much of which was used for emergency
student financial aid
the president will continue fighting to
double the maximum pell grant and to
make community colleges
universally free
this is as i said a comprehensive plan
that will provide meaningful relief to
millions of americans both now and in
the future
targeting this relief to those
who need it the most
means that ninety percent
of the relief dollars ninety percent of
the relief dollars will go to those
individuals earning less than seventy
five thousand dollars a year
and no individual or couple in the top
five percent of incomes in the united
states will receive a penny of relief
of the 43 million
eligible borrowers
more than 60 percent
or 27 million individuals are pell grant
recipients who are eligible to receive
up to 20 thousand dollars in debt
cancellation
over sixty percent
among black borrowers for example
seventy one percent receive pell grants
so today's announcement will have a
significant impact on people who have
been disproportionately impacted by
student debt
nearly two-thirds of individuals
all debtors
will have half or more
of their total debt wiped out
including the 20 million borrowers who
will have their debt completely
eliminated
that's 45 of the total 20 million
borrowers will have their debt
completely eliminated two-thirds will
have half or more eliminated
the actions we are announcing today are
going to be good for our economy we are
on track to cut the federal deficit by
more than 1.7 trillion dollars this year
the single largest deficit reduction
ever
and numerous experts affirm that
restarting paused loan repayments at
around the same time as we provide
targeted
debt relief
will not have any meaningful effect on
inflation
finally this action will ease the
financial burden on millions of
americans and provide them with greater
economic security to buy a house
start a family open a business or save
for retirement
and that is good for all americans
the president has always promised
that he will build an economy from the
bottom up and the middle out
today's announcement is just one more
step
we're taking to make that a reality
thank you
okay right now
come on come on
all right so we have about 15 minutes as
i just stated
april go ahead um ambassador rice i have
uh three questions if you will one
what um made the president move off of
that ten thousand he was so adamant on
the twenty thousand as chuck schumer and
the rest on capitol hill elizabeth
warren ariana presley were calling for
50 000.
also when it comes to pell grants your
mother was known as the mother of the
pell grant system president biden just
said himself
that
80
80
of
the monies
helped students and now that money's
going it's dropped down to 30 when it
comes to pell grant are you doing
anything to bolster the pell grant
system as you're trying to um
relieve this this student loan debt and
lastly whoa whoa when we take one at a
time okay
all right first of all let's talk about
the pell grant pell grant is 50 years
old this year
when the pell grant was established it
covered 80 percent
of the cost of a four-year public
institution
today it's now 30 percent that's because
costs of college have gone up and the
relative size of the pell grant has gone
down
the president has been very clear from
the campaign forward that he aims to
double the maximum
grant the maximum size of the pell grant
to around thirteen thousand dollars from
its current level around sixty five
hundred
he has in his budget requests asked for
incremental increases to get to that
doubling and his fy 23 budget request
does that as well in the fy 2 of 22
appropriation
enacted
dollars uh was added to the maximum size
of the pell grant which as i said in my
remarks is the largest increase in the
decade
um with respect to the president's
posture on this he's been clear from the
campaign that he was prepared to
relieve up to ten thousand dollars
in broad-based cancellation
he has listened and consulted and
studied as
in partnership with the department of
education which obviously has a lead on
this as to what is the best approach
and after
all of that consultation the secretary
of education
made the determination
that the best way to benefit those who
need it most consistent with the
president's campaign proposal
but actually more advantageous
for those in the lower income
part of the spectrum those who have been
most harmed would be to have the twenty
thousand dollars of relief um for those
who are pell grant recipients below the
income threshold
in addition to ten thousand for those
also below the income threshold um who
were not pell grant recipients and then
my last question friday there is a
meeting uh we understand what the
president and civil rights leaders are
all encompassing to include this could
you talk about uh that meeting by any
chance no i can't preview a meeting that
hasn't so it is happening okay i'm not i
can't confirm that okay that's a silly
thing
mayor master i have a couple of
questions for you
one i want to get your your general
response to this overwhelming chorus of
critics republicans right now who say
this is unfair
that there are people who decided to not
go to college because they couldn't pay
for it there are people who decided to
join the armed forces in lieu of going
to college because they couldn't pay for
it and this leaves them behind is there
inaccuracy in any of that yes there is
an accuracy that but there's also a
double standard and this is a debate we
are happy to have first of all
republicans didn't complain when certain
small businesses during the pandemic got
extraordinary uh financial relief
and and without having to pay back those
loans but
when some businesses needed it and other
businesses didn't need it this is the
same principle we have a country where
we all benefit where the middle and
working class are doing well this
relief will be targeted to those who
need it most as i said ninety percent
of those who will benefit earn less than
seventy five thousand dollars a year so
this is not a giveaway to rich people
this is not uh any of the things that uh
republican critics have charged yes
those who have paid their loans back
deserve
to be credited that's fantastic that's
to their uh to their credit but that
doesn't mean that those who are for
whatever reason
unable to pay back their loans like you
know one-third of people have debt and
no college degree
um that doesn't mean that because
the some were able to do so nobody
should help those who weren't by that
logic we wouldn't help anybody in this
country how much will this cost how much
will americans have to pay on this price
tag overall well that that that remains
to be determined and it will be a
function of what percentage of eligible
borrowers
actually take up this opportunity 800
billion
we'll see what when they take up the
opportunity we'll be able to give you uh
a much better sense of that
ballpark at this point i think it
depends on the numbers like you know
unfortunately and we're here to
encourage as many people to take it up
as possible if if 43 million borrowers
uh take it up that'll be different than
if 50 of those 43 million take it up if
it is 43 million if i could just follow
on you know if the full number of
eligible uh borrowers do take advantage
of the program what would the cost be i
i can't give you that off top of my head
and just wait wait
i thought you were running this yeah i
know i know she slipped in on me you're
you're right you're right ambassador go
ahead in the back okay
can you talk about sort of the timeline
here from sort of when this now becomes
available to borrowers and sort of how
long they may have and
i guess the sort because i know the
president talked about you have to apply
for this this isn't going to be
automatic right so i mean people may not
even know necessarily if they're
eligible right okay so this is a great
question thank you for asking
first of all
uh
anybody can go today
to
studentaid.gov
and provide their email address and they
will be notified when the website is
available for people to uh
fill out a very simple short form a
testing to their income and and uh and
become eligible
having said that as well down the road
it it is likely that as many as 8
million americans
are automatically eligible because the
department of education already has
their income information because they
filled out a financial aid form for
example
so
we estimate that there will be some 20
percent roughly who will get automatic
relief because they qualify and we know
they qualify and can verify that
then subsequently over the coming weeks
but in advance of the
the pause expiring one final time
there will be the capacity for people to
go to a department of education website
and
do the quick short form at test station
and
become eligible good michael
thank you
just a couple of quick technical
questions can you talk a little bit
about the legal authority on which this
program is based um and
is there a worry that colleges will not
now be incentivized to simply raise
tuition rates
since they
know both because of the cancellation
but also because of the
reduction in the maximum payment that
people will have to pay going forward
that should provide a buffer for
colleges to just raise tuition because
they know that
more students will be able to afford the
higher cost because their the maximum
will be will be capped and just one last
thing is wait
wait okay give me a bear do me
uh see now you've already made me forget
the first one the first the first the
first one was the legal authority okay
uh congress gave the secretary of
education and the heroes act the
authority to do this uh and i'll refer
you to the department of education and
and their general counsel for the
details
with respect to your second question
about costs of colleges you heard the
president emphasize in his remarks and a
key element of
our plan is to
ensure that colleges that have jacked up
prices and taken advantage of students
particularly those that have made wild
promises about how much people will be
able to
earn based on their degree program which
are not backed up by reality and while
people are earning are incurring huge
volumes of debt that is something the
department of education has already
cracked down on and is going to continue
to crack down on
there's also the reality that the
american
rescue plan provided both in state and
local funds
as well as in funds targeted to higher
education
significant dollars
that can and should be used to
make sure that public institutions don't
increase their
um
tuition and expenses greater than the
rate of inflation and
the department of education is going to
be vigilant they are going to publish
annually a list of institutions that are
the worst actors in terms of the the
delta between what they promise what
they charge and what they deliver and
finally one last question is is it
possible for somebody to go out today
and apply for a college loan knowing
that it's
that it's going to be canceled or is
there what what is the date by which
somebody had to
the loans that are eligible for relief
um were those that were
up until june 30th
of this year june 30th 2022.
uh rob i'm not going to let you escape
no he's not going to escape i was like
who's gonna ask a
i i know there's been some officials
that have taken an issue with some of
the top line estimates we've seen from
outsiders in terms of cost not to
mention kind of the view of
direct impact on inflation and how
things made that out but you can't even
give a top-line figure for if the uptake
was everyone how are you modeling this
out and what gives you certainty that
even an intent of a basis point in a
very high inflation environment wouldn't
be problematic
great so let's take that in two parts so
the first question is what's the cost
and as ambassador rice said there's a
number of factors that go into that
question
there's the take-up rate right folks are
going to have to go apply for relief
our hope is that 100 of people who are
eligible go apply for relief and get the
relief that they're entitled to i think
realistically we're not going to get to
100 but the question is how far short of
100 are we going to be and that plays a
big role in what the cost is going to be
the second aspect is that
look the student loan portfolio there
are different estimates about repayment
rates and default rates right right now
in the student loan portfolio 16 of
borrowers are in default
and if you look at the category of
borrowers there's millions of borrowers
who are more than seven years in default
the median amount of money that the
department of education collects from
those borrowers each year is zero
dollars
so even if the those borrowers have a
face value on their debt of ten thousand
dollars and this plan wipes it out it's
not reasonable to say that the cost of
that is ten thousand dollars because we
were not realistically going to collect
anywhere close to ten thousand dollars
from it so the assumptions and the
analysis about how much are we expecting
to collect some of that changes over
time based on certain macroeconomic
conditions and other factors
the third thing we have to to pay
attention to here is in evaluating the
cost of this program we have to also
evaluate the benefits and how that will
flow into revenue to the government you
know our view is based on a lot of good
empirical literature
relieving student loan debt burden is
going to help people start small
businesses it's going to make it easier
for certain folks to actually save for
that down payment and buy a home
all of that additional economic activity
in the medium term is going to create
additional tax revenue that comes into
the government that offsets the cost on
the front end
so the the bottom line here is that
there's all these different factors that
go into the cost standing here today i
can't tell you how all of those are
going to shake out
part of it is that the department of
education has to actually implement this
policy they have to get the application
out we have to start getting data on how
many people are applying and i think
then you know when that happens well a
better sense of what the cost is going
to be
on inflation
i think it's good to to take a step back
and realize where we are today
today the the student loan payments are
paused they've been paused since the
previous administration
and it's been extended multiple times by
the secretary of education
because of the pause you have 45 million
borrowers who are not required to make a
single dollar in payments right now
what the president announced today was
not only this debt relief but a
resumption in payments
on january 1st 2023
when you resume payments what that means
is that millions of borrowers
are going to start making payments that
come into the federal government it's
going to be billions of dollars a month
in payments coming into the federal
government at the same time of course
there is going to be relief going out to
people and our view is that those two
things the relief going out to people
and the money coming in from restart
largely offset each other
and we're not alone in thinking that a
number of independent experts who've
weighed in on this topic today have said
the exact same thing mark zandy at moody
said that
mike konzel at the roosevelt institute
and others that we can point you to so
uh our view is that uh these two uh will
largely offset one another and in fact
according to some independent experts it
could actually be deflationary given all
the money that's coming in
after payments received how are you
modeling assumptions about repayment
when the same macro effects in terms of
whether or not people are going to be
prepared to repay whether they're going
to be preparing immediately when it
actually happens how can you make that
assumption if you can't make assumptions
about from the uptake sure
well i can tell you in the pre-pandemic
pre-pause era each month the department
of education would collect about six
billion dollars worth of payments from
borrowers
uh during the pause uh believe it or not
a a number of people are actually making
payments voluntarily and so we're
actually collecting about two billion
dollars in payments so that delta
between what we would normally collect
and what we're collecting now is about
four billion dollars a month
uh when we restart the assumption would
be that we would roughly speaking these
are estimates start collecting that four
billion dollars again with a bit of a
discount because obviously certain
borrowers are going to get relief
including some borrowers who are going
to have their loans completely wiped out
but the but the main thing we have to
understand here is that today
we are going to we are collecting 2
billion a month in voluntary payments
and after the restart happens we are
going to be collecting something
significantly above 2 billion a month
from borrowers and if you think about
that at a very basic level that's why
there's that deflationary impact from
the restart
um just to follow up on the legal
authority i know you said that uh we
should check with the department of
education but in terms of at least the
way the administration has talked about
it um you've touted the economy and how
it's doing much better under the
president's management of the pandemic
so how does that align with then using
legal authority citing pandemic
emergency yeah
i used to be a lawyer but i'm not a
lawyer anymore so i don't want to
venture out onto getting deep into the
into the legal authority here and i
would refer you to the department of
justice
office of legal counsel and also to the
department of education office of
general counsel but i will make the
point that
there is a concern that when payments
resume in january that that's going to
lead to
an increase in financial distress among
borrowers
and so for example if you look at
there's a small subset of borrowers for
particular reasons who are not subject
to the payment pause so they've been
having to make their payments throughout
the pandemic and what you've seen is
that
those borrowers are in more financial
distress they've been having a harder
time
making payments on other debts that they
owe and so on so the concern is that
when you restart payments are a subset
of borrowers
going to end up defaulting on their
loans are they going to go into
delinquency and so part of what the
legal authority is being used to do here
in a targeted way
is to make sure that those borrowers who
are at highest risk of distress after
the restart happens those are the people
who are going to get the relief because
the the legal authority gives the
secretary the ability to make sure that
the pandemic and the emergency does not
cause a net financial harm to those
folks
okay two more
if you take a closer look at the white
house fact sheet that was released um
the white house cites a construction
worker who makes 38 000 a year as a
potential candidate for for this student
loan relief you also cite a 77
a year earning nurse
and that sounds great but i'm wondering
why did you structure this policy in a
way that would provide up to forty
thousand dollars in debt for a married
couple making up to 249 000
i mean why include folks who have gone
to post grad you know law school or
business school is that really
bottom up middle out
uh yeah it is you know
as we've made clear nobody in the top
five percent of incomes is going to get
a single dollar under this proposal
and actually we have very good data
showing that folks even making uh in
that range that we talked about that
near the top of the income cutoff
are much more likely to be experiencing
distress after repayment starts there's
good data on it and look again
as ambassador wright said we welcome
having this debate if you look at this
chart
you can see that 87 percent of the
dollars overall are going to to people
making under 75 000 a year
uh and zero dollars zero percent are
going to anybody making over 125
thousand dollars in individual income
and just because i've seen some
criticism from from republicans on this
today it's instructive to compare that
to what the republican tax bill did in
2017 it's basically the reverse
15 percent of the benefits went to
people making under 75 000 a year and 85
percent went to people making over 75
000 a year and if you zoom in even more
on that
uh people making over 250 000 a year got
nearly half of the benefits of the gop
tax bill and are getting zero dollars
under our bill so
we think that this is a classic example
of what the president talks about in
middle up economics it's going to
families that really need it and the
vast majority of it is going to people
making under 75 000 a year
so my question is
how did the administration come up with
the twenty thousand and ten thousand
dollar relief number was there some kind
of calculation into what would be
inflationary and what is actually going
to make an impact yeah
look
in terms of the secretary's decision and
the president's decision on this there's
a number of factors that go into it the
president's goal was to do something
that he thought was fair
uh responsible
and consistent with his commitment to
fiscal responsibility and and the
conclusion was that uh
following through on his campaign
commitment doing ten thousand dollars uh
for most borrowers and then adding this
additional ten thousand dollars for pell
recipients uh which it should be noted
a couple of facts about pell recipients
uh almost all of them come from families
that make under sixty thousand dollars a
year um half of them came from families
that made under thirty thousand dollars
a year
uh and and targeting additional money to
people who got pell grants
also reflects the fact that when it
comes to repaying your debt
part of what matters is your current
income
but a big part of it too is what how
much wealth do you have what assets can
you rely upon you know a lot of
borrowers can rely upon family wealth to
help make some of those payments
especially as they're starting out pell
grant recipients because they come from
families with lower wealth
can't rely on that family wealth as much
in fact some of them many of them are
actually helping members of their family
pay their other debts so we thought this
was a fair and equitable thing to do it
was fiscally responsible
and the combination of those factors is
why we arrived at this ultimate outcome
thank you thanks guys
thank you ambassador
thank you guys
all right i have one quick thing at the
top and then we'll get going the rest of
the briefing
so the last time i stood before you uh
all here on august 9th average national
gas prices were four dollars and three
cents today the average national
prices are 3.88
the most common price at gas stations
across the country today is 3.49
prices have come down every single day
since the last briefing
in fact they've come down every single
day
this summer
over 10 straight weeks this is the
fastest decline in gas prices in over a
decade and it is saving families with
two cars a hundred and twenty dollars
per month
on average
president biden promised he would
address putin's price hike at the pump
and he has
he's releasing one million barrels of
oil a day with the strategic petroleum
reserve
he brought together international
partners to release an unprecedented
amount of oil and under president
biden's leadership u.s oil production is
up and on track to reach a record high
the president will continue to call on
domestic and international oil producers
and refiners to increase output so that
prices can continue to come down with
that
go ahead omelette thank you um i suppose
i just wanted to follow up on something
that came up in kirby's gaggle uh this
morning i he said that
you have no
damage assessment uh within the nsc
going underway
about uh regarding the documents that
were found in the
fbi search at mar-a-lago
and i guess my question is
why
[Music]
from my understanding
there is an intelligence directive um
that calls for there uh to be that
damages assessment to be conducted when
there's an actual or suspected breach of
classified information
um i understand not wanting to get
involved in the um justice department's
investigation but why isn't um the
administration assessing
what potential damage may have come from
uh so
look i'm just going to reiterate what
you heard
from my colleague we're just not going
to comment on any of the contents of the
ongoing
independent justice department
investigation
again and i you have heard this from me
you've heard this from others when it
comes to that
we would refer you to the department of
justice and i'm respectfully i just i'm
not asking you to comment on
the justice department's investigation
i'm asking you whether there is an
assessment going on uh to just
understand just what
what's what if any damage has been done
to protect american national security
yeah and i i am answering your question
when it comes to any underlying
materials or any conduct uh contents of
the ongoing investigation
we are just the independent department
of justice investigation we're just not
going to comment on it follow up on that
and if i may you talk just file the
lawsuit
over the president's decision to
reinstate the boundaries of the bears
ears and brand staircase uh
national monuments so is this
administration have any um
reaction to this lawsuit no i'm not
going to comment on the lawsuit from
here okay
does the white and white house believe
it's ethical to raid the home of the top
political opponent about the uh the
airstrikes ordered by the president
against iranian-backed groups in syria
yesterday and it what impact of any that
would have on uh in iranian nuclear
negotiations
yeah so um
the
the syria um
as as you heard from sitcom uh today
these strikes were a direct
response to attacks on ongoing threats
against u.s forces so we don't we do not
seek escalation as you heard from uh
from sitcom but we remain prepared to
respond to any ongoing threat so i just
want to say that at the top we took this
action because
the president determined it was in our
national security interest to do so
he will continue to closely monitor the
situation with his national security
team so that is something that we're
going to continue to do as it relates to
the jcpoa to your question uh you know
the president said this that his pledge
to prevent iran from acquiring a nuclear
weapon
he wants to prevent that that has been
his pledge from from the beginning
a nuclear-armed iran would serve as an
even greater threat to u.s forces
friends and allies in the region the
president will use whatever means
are necessary to prevent iran from
acquiring a nuclear weapon the preferred
course of course you've heard us say
this from this podium many times you've
heard us say this uh the president say
this is diplomacy uh but it remains to
be seen whether a deal is actually
achievable but that's what we are that's
what we're going to work towards a
diplomacy effort whether or not there is
a deal the president's commitment to
protect u.s personnel and confront
iran's activities that jeopardize our
our people or our friends in the region
is unwavering and uh the nuclear deal
has nothing to do with our readiness and
ability uh to defend our people in our
interests and that's going to be the pro
the president's primary focus on ukraine
the most recently announced weapons
package uh i understand that those
weapons have to be built they're not in
a stockpile already what is the range
there for in kind of estimated time they
could actually be delivered to ukraine
no it's a great question i think what
you saw us announce the three billion
dollars from folks for folks who are not
tracking which a new package which is uh
the largest
one one at once uh trench that we've
announced from this administration
uh we've have announced approximately
13.6 billion just to give a little bit
of of a context there of security
assistance for ukraine since the
beginning of this administration back in
january of 2021 an unprecedented amount
that is roughly three times
what ukraine's annual military budget is
but so to your point this is through the
ukrainian security assistance this
announcement represents the beginning of
a contracting process
through which dod will acquire
additional capabilities to provide to
ukraine's armed forces this is different
than the presidential
down drawdown authorities that you've
heard us announce so it means that some
of this
acquiring ukraine will take some time to
your point i don't have a specific
timeline for this i would refer you to
the department of defense but this
announcement is part of our efforts to
ensure ukraine's military can continue
to defend uh its people and also it can
defend its freedom uh and it's this
defend its right to be a sovereign
country
okay
um a federal judge today blocked the
administration's ability to enforce
guidance uh related to emergency
services abortion affairs and states
where it's banned or restricted um i
think you've got three more states that
are adding new restrictions return your
laws at some point this week when you
look around at the environment right now
where is the administration in terms of
potentially new actions or what the
president is thinking as this continues
to progress as you know the president
has taken some bold actions since
dobbs decision was made back in june of
20 june 24th i believe so just a couple
months ago
and you know we've been very clear as
you look at what's uh what is uh what
happened last night in texas uh you know
republicans legislators are working to
roll back uh the freedoms of americans
that they relied on for a half a century
a half a century and it's more and more
clear that this is against the will of
majority of americans
and we cannot forget that women across
the country are making their voices
heard they're making their voices really
loud and clear to reclaim the rights
that were taken from them by the supreme
court and so here's the thing that we're
doing what the president is doing and
what congressional
democrats are doing is listening
and to to women to the american to
majority of americans and we're
committed to restoring uh protections of
roe
but again what we're seeing from the
other side is is is extreme
it is ultra mega as you've heard the
president say
it is it is uh you know it's including
banning
abortion in cases of rape incest and the
health of the mother that is what
is happening here when you look at these
pieces of legislation just across the
country and as i mentioned last night
texas district court affirmed that
medical providers can deny life-saving
and health preserving care for women
even if they are suffering from
hemorrhaging or life-threatening
hypertension
that is what we're seeing and tomorrow
five new abortion bans go into effect in
idaho
north dakota oklahoma tennessee and
texas that will criminalize abortion in
some cases without exceptions for rape
or incest texas law is extreme that is
that that it seeks to punish health
care providers with life in prison
that's what they're talking about
punishing health care providers with
life
in prison so americans need to know that
these are our fundamental rights that
were taken away from us by this dob
decision
including the right to contraception and
marriage equality are at risk let's not
forget what we heard
from judge
thomas when that decision was put down
was uh was announced that's why people
across the country need to
make sure that their voices are being
heard and that's what we're going to
continue to do that's what the president
is going to do along with congressional
democrats okay thank you on student
loans one of my colleagues asked if
these measures
are likely to raise prices because it
makes it easier for some students or
maybe more willing to take on debt if
they know they're only going to have to
pay minimum amount or if it's going to
be forgiven
and ambassador rice said that's
something the department of education is
going to be on the lookout for so i'm
wondering if that's a tacit
acknowledgement that yes these policies
could cause tuition rates to rise in the
near future even further than they
already have look this is
this is something that ambassador
ambassador rice talked about as you just
stated she she was asked this question a
couple of times and she said we have to
see right we have to see this is
something that the department of
education is going to look into
in particular with
with when you talk about colleges
potentially raising
prices that's something that the
department of education is looking at
and is going to crack down on but it
seems like it's something you're
preparing for right well i mean look
this is again this is something that the
department of education is aware of this
is something that we're monitoring uh
but it doesn't take away from what this
means from what we what the president
announced today this is going to help
people making less than 125 000
uh that matters this is going to help 90
percent of what uh of of what the
president announced of this package that
the president announced is going to help
americans middle class americans who are
making uh who are making less than 75
000 a year this is giving those
americans a little bit of breathing room
let's forget what let's not forget what
has happened the last couple of years if
you think about the pandemic if you
think about how people are still
recovering from the pandemic we're
trying to make sure that people still
have a little bit of breathing room
especially as the pause is going to be
lifted as the president announced as you
heard from
from the ambassador at the end of this
year so we want to make sure again that
we are focused on the middle class that
we are focused on the economy helping
folks from the bottom up in the middle
out this has been part of the
president's economic policy
if you look just across the board the
american rescue plan if you look at the
bipartisan
bipartisan infrastructure law if you
look at what we've done
these past several weeks several weeks
with congress with democrats in congress
the inflation reduction act all of this
is part of making sure that we don't
leave people behind people who have been
left behind for generations so that's
our focus
tackle what you can address now and if
that causes college to be more expensive
in the future that's something you'll
address later well this is so again this
is something that the department of
education is is going to be
zero focused on laser focused on uh and
uh make sure that uh you know we crack
down uh on those particular issues that
you know that particular issue that you
just brought up but again this is this
is a big deal what's happening this is a
big deal for so many
americans who who go into debt uh
because they're not able uh to to uh you
know because they have to pay uh these
loans and so this again will give them a
little bit more of a breathing room
which is something that you hear from
the president uh every time he talks
about the economy and what his focus is
on okay on that note though i guess what
prevents the cycle of debt from
continuing right because there will be
students no doubt that coming here who
are going to take on more loads and i
guess i'm i'm still confused as to how
the cycle of debt
is really broken i mean when you think
about
when you think about this was in our
fact sheets which i think is really
important uh to state is how much uh how
much relief this will provide to 43
million borrowers including cancelling
full remaining balance for roughly 20
million borrowers like that matters
that matters to borrowers and their
family
who are in high school right now going
in it's sort of like no solutions
well look i think what you're talking
about the future is that what you're
talking about
you're talking about okay
okay well well let me well here's the
thing there are things the president
plan also provides relief to future
borrowers and current buyers by cutting
monthly payments for undergraduate loans
in half like that is part of the plan
yes we talk about ten thousand payment
not the principal and that's what we're
getting at is it's actually making it
easier for people to take on more debt
and there's nothing in this program that
stops schools for i mean just
anecdotally my school raised tuition
from the time i was a freshman at the
time i was a senior my scholarship
didn't go with it so yeah i had to take
out private events to cover that and
again that is something that the
department of education is closely
looking at that is what the the that is
what the ambassador was saying right
this is something when it comes to
schools doing that that is something
that the department of education is
going to crack down on uh so again we'll
we'll refer you to them that is clearly
something that we are monitoring and is
important as well make a very good point
it is not lost on us
uh
again department of education i'm just
going to repeat what the what the
ambassador said is looking into that
they're monitoring that they're going to
crack down on that and have a plan to do
that
and so that that is in their wheelhouse
to deal with that particular issue one
more question which is i do know that
there have been concerns that
that the plan could be struck down in
courts in some ways this is even
something that the democratic think tank
third way came out saying and my
question is for you all what preparation
is there into thinking people will apply
for this program and they could be stuck
in some legal limbo
well look
um and
ambassador rice talked about this that
this is what we
the legal authority that we took is uh
pretty much consistent with the heroes
act right which is what she talked about
which authorizes the secretary of
education to take certain actions he
believes they are necessary to ensure
borrowers not
not placed in a worse position
financially due to a national emergency
like the kova 19 pandemic so that is the
act that is the legal authority uh that
was given to the secretary of education
to do this we are confident uh in that
legal authority uh and any other further
specific questions on that i would refer
you to department of education
[Music]
i haven't called in you and i'll come
back
i just wanted to return
real quick on the damn potential damage
assessment
related to the documents um and ask you
i mean it sounds like you're not
commenting
period i mean is that right or are you
um i'm trying to figure out like if
there's a possibility that there is an
assessment going on you're just not
willing to say it or is there no
assessment going so i cannot comment on
on it at all
i all i can say is at this time when it
comes to these underlying materials when
it comes to the contents of the ongoing
investigation this is something that it
is an independent investigation that the
department of justice is doing and i
would refer you to them but it would
seem logical that the administration
for national security reasons would want
to assess
whether that something was was breached
it's separate from an investigation into
whether or not i know i mean i get your
question i i hear it i i get your
question
armor just asked the same question i
think it might have been a follow-up
after that uh it's we're just are not
going to comment on the contents of the
uh of this ongoing independent
investigation the department of justice
is doing we're not going to comment on
the underlying materials at at this time
we're just not going to do that
to that um just another quick question
tomorrow at ukraine is independence day
um
john kirby said earlier that president
biden would be calling president
zielinski is there anything else that
the administration is doing obviously
this comes right after the three billion
dollars in aid that you outline but i
don't know if there's anything else that
the administration is doing
well the three billion dollars
of assistance that we announced which is
the largest one one at one time
assistance that we've provided i think
shows our commitment our long-term this
is a long-term commitment
to ukraine to continue to fight for
their freedom
and bravely as they have been doing
for the past six months
as as you heard from my colleague yes
the president's going to have a
conversation with president zielinski
which he's had multiple conversations uh
with him in the past several months
there's been an open line of
communication with not just
the president zielinski but also
his team in the government and
we'll likely have a readout and we'll
share more of that conversation but the
president wanted to make sure he touched
base uh with president directly and
that's what's going to happen tomorrow
my colleagues have made the point and
actually democratic congressman chris
pappas issued a statement to the effect
that this plan regarding college debt
doesn't address the underlying cost of
college so kind of honing in on a
question that my colleagues have asked
is the president ready to do more when
it comes to addressing the underlying
and ever increasing costs of college is
he willing to work with congress is this
something he's going to address more in
the future well he's talked about uh
he's talked about that in the past right
he's talked about what he's he wants to
make sure that
we lower costs right uh uh of college uh
for uh for students look since 1980 the
total cost of both four-year public and
four-year private college has nearly
tripled even after accounting for
inflation federal support has not kept
up
pell grants once covered nearly 80
percent of the cost of a four-year
public college degree for students from
working families but now only covered a
third the typical undergraduate student
with loans now
graduates with nearly twenty five
thousand dollars in debt and so this is
something that is going to help deal
with that specific issue look the
president has done has done he's taken
multiple actions we're looking at
today's actions but if you think about
uh the 32 billion dollars that he was
able to do to give debt relief to more
than 1.6 million
borrowers that is something that he has
done in his this administration that is
historic
that was a historic effort this is part
of it with the if you think about the
pause how much that has saved
americans who have not been who have not
had to pay a dollar you've heard that
from his speech today of of uh of
repayment since uh since he's got into
office which started before
this president this president just
continued the the efforts so that
matters that is also important so we
just want to make sure that is clear as
well uh you know this is this is going
to help
millions and millions of people uh who
who you know you think about the pell
grant that was discussed a moment ago
you can get if you if you have a
recipient of the pell grant and you are
a
borrower of course you can that goes up
to 20
000
and that matters because people who are
on the pell grant uh they come from
households that makes less than sixty
thousand dollars that matters half of
that are folks in house household that
makes less than thirty thousand so all
of the these efforts are going to uh to
matter they're gonna have an effect uh
and what you heard from my colleagues
who were just here moments ago uh
they're gonna encourage people to take
to take that to take this opportunity uh
to help them with those efforts i'm
gonna i'm just gonna move around i'm
just gonna move around go ahead thank
you we have two questions in in recent
months there have been increasing
instances of vandalism of gandhi statue
or two of them have been in new york
and one of them has been treated as a
hate crime uh is the president aware
about it because both the president vice
president have often
quoted mahatma gandhi's quotes during
their speeches and they accept their
great friends
what is the president god says to them
because these
preen gentlemen openly commenting on
social media about vandalism of gandhi
statue so
gandhi
as you know is has enduring message
of truth and non-violence serves as an
inspiration as you said the president
has spoken to this directly and
specifically
any act of vandals vandalism should be
condemned in the strongest terms
i'll refer you to the local law
enforcement for more on any
investigation or actions that may be
taken
from that uh from from their point of
view the united states is committed to
ensuring the safety of security and
indian and other foreign counterparts so
we are something that we condemned
any acts of violence you've heard us say
this many times before from this podium
and again you know mahatma gandhi is an
inspiration and that's and you've heard
that directly from the president many
times
in the afternoon
russian invasion of ukraine
a lot of people are saying that the
india use relationship is drifting apart
do you believe that so i think you asked
me about the indian independence and we
had a a pretty strong uh response to how
we see our relationship with india
it's a it's indispensable we see we see
the the the partners as indispensable
partners and the us india strategic
partnership is grounded in our shared
commitment
to the advancement of a free and open
indo-pacific region you've heard the
president say this the rule of law and
the promotion of human freedom and
dignity
we are confident in our relationship
and in the years ahead we'll continue to
stand together to defend
the rules-based order foster greater
peace prosperity and security for our
people
advance a free and open in indo-pacific
and together address the challenges we
face around the world uh together so we
we see this as a a commitment as a
continued partnership do you have
differences of india on the issue of
ukraine
look we've been very clear on where we
stand
with ukraine and we just announced a
three billion dollar uh additional
security assistance uh to uh to to the
country to make sure that the people are
continuing uh to fight for their freedom
we have been it's not just us you see
that with our allies and partners you
see a a a very unified nato uh that and
they are unified because of the
leadership of this president
you're seeing that data was going to
expand by two more countries so this
shows uh the strength and the west and
how much we have come together in
supporting
ukraine and so we've been very clear on
where we stand it is important to make
sure that when a country is fighting for
their freedom fighting for their
democracy
for their sovereignty and that we
support that
thanks green about the student loans how
can the country afford
such a massive handout
yeah well you know uh
ambassador rice said that she's happy to
have that discussion i'm happy to have
this discussion as well uh look if you
look at what this president has done uh
if you look at the end of this this
coming and end of the fiscal year 1.7
trillion dollars that we have deduced
brought down uh the deficit that matters
that matters and if you look at the
inflation reduction act it's going to
add another 300 billion dollars is going
to uh bring down the deficit again and
you might spend 300 to 900
billion dollars extra so you can do that
and not
but here's the thing here's the thing
what we are trying to do here we are
doing this responsibly
uh you heard directly from the president
this is something that is going to be
important for middle class americans
when you think about 90 percent
of the folks who are
who are going to actually benefit from
this are making 75 000 or less and you
think about what republicans did just a
couple of years ago
they they signed off on a 2 trillion
3 trillion dollar tax cut for the
wealthy and did not provide any way to
pay for that and that again here's what
we have done here's what here's about
how much it might cost it might not cost
who is paying for this what we are
saying is the the work that this
administration has done the work that
the democrats in congress has done is
actually there and you see that the 1.7
trillion
deficit in deficit deduction that you
see is is going to benefit us in being
able to do something for the middle
class to do something for the middle
class
this is about doing something for people
who make less than 125 000
1.7 trillion dollars that's what we've
been able to do but when you forgive
debt you're not just disappearing debt
so who is paying for it
and then i'll give you the second part
we lifted the pause right we're going to
lift the paws
at the end of this year which is going
to matter right which is going to offset
a lot of what what we're doing as well
when you think about the the four
billion dollars that are going that's
going to go back uh into as as revenue
back into
this process of folks paying paying
right their college tuition that matters
as well so we are doing this in a smart
way we're doing this in a way that's
going to be effective we're doing in
this a way that keeps to the president's
promise on giving people who need some
breathing room who needs to bring their
work
i just i just laid out i just laid out
for you no peter i just laid out for you
how we're seeing this process and why
this matters
again i just laid out i just i just laid
out because of the work that we have
done in the economy because of the
american rescue plan
because of the inflation reduction act
and because all of this work that this
president has done is actually has
brought down our deficit by 1.7 trillion
dollars unlike what republicans did when
they added to our deficit 2 trillion
dollars and did not care at all or
thought about how this was going to be
paid for they did not actually put in a
process or thought think about how we're
going to do this in a smart way this is
not how this administration is doing it
again we are happy to continue to have
this conversation but i'm going to move
around go ahead april
i'm sorry
i'm kareem so what i need to find out
the school system for 2022 2023 is
already beginning to see
cracks
school teachers um there are school
teacher shortages in some states
there are attacks already on some kids
who are in the lgbtq community there's a
concern about crime
is the president working with the
secretary of education like he did
on the student loan debt forgiveness to
talk about trying to ensure the safety
the equity
and just the success
of the 2023-20 22 20 23 school year yeah
this is something that uh the secretary
has talked about secretary uh cardona
specifically he's he's been on a few
networks and was asked uh recently i
believe this past sunday some sunday
shows and asked about the upcoming
school year was asked about the teachers
was asked about the equity piece if you
think about the american rescue plan and
you think about what that did the
billions of dollars that that provided
to make sure that school districts were
able to rehire
teachers especially what was happen what
we saw was happening with the pandemic
where we
teachers left
left the field where we saw schools shut
down because of the pandemic and because
of the work that this president did
because of the work that congressional
democrats did we were able to get those
schools open where
jurisdictions and school districts were
able to hire
teachers and that matters that is
important we're continuing you've heard
this from secretary cordona he's
continuing he's going to continue to
work
with local
local
governments local schools to make sure
that the american rescue plan the monies
that are there
to to hire those teachers are being used
and so that's one piece right that's the
teachers
and also you know the president has put
forth
billions of dollars more than 300
billion dollars from from the american
rescue plan to make sure that there is
safety that peop that that communities
were able to hire
police officers to make sure that there
was some protection that they felt safe
had safe communities
what about the piece the attack
on
students who are in the lgbt community
from telling them they can't come to
school or not feeding them school
lunches
is that a rights issue as well so we
first of all we condemn that uh
you know this president you know how
this president feels about inequities uh
how he he's been very clear about making
sure that we protect
young people
especially in the lgbtq community we
have spoken out about that many times
this is something that secretary cardona
is working with with
with local schools
and he has talked about as well so this
is clearly an issue that we're
monitoring we'll continue to monitor
monitor and we will continue to condemn
those types of practices or behavior
i'm i'm going to just go around to
people i haven't called on yet go ahead
dan i agree um i have two questions
the uh state of california
is scheduled tomorrow to say that you
can't
buy new electric car new gasoline cars
in starting 20 30 35. what is the white
house's reaction to that do you guys
support that
say that one more time california said
after 2035 they're not going to let you
buy new gasoline cars there's
that news is breaking tomorrow okay so i
have not seen that report so i need to
actually take a look talk to our team so
we can provide you a more uh a a clear
you know a a clear response um so i i
don't want to get ahead of of of what
the team might say on that
uh what do you say to jason furman he
was the chairman of the council of
economic advisers during the obama white
house
and he uh tweeted today he was he and
larry summers were you know early
uh you know warning beacons on inflation
last year he tweeted pouring roughly
half a trillion dollars of gasoline on
the inflationary fire that is already
burning as reckless
doing it while going beyond one campaign
promise and breaking another is even
worse how do you respond to that you're
talking about the student the student
loan
from your own party look
you know barack kind of talked about
this uh
you know
the way we see it is a number of
independent experts from moody's
analysts to the economic policy
institute agree that restarting student
loan payments around the same time we
provide
targeted relief will not have any
meaningful effect on inflation that's
because collecting more payments by
ending the moratorium will mean borrows
will
pull back on spending in other areas it
will have a deflationary effect that's
the way
that experts have seen this as well this
will more than outweigh any limited
positive wealth effect of targeted debt
cancellation that's why the economic
policy institute has said that that
claim
that cancelling debt is inflate
inflationary is profoundly off base and
the roosevelt institute has even has
gone even further to say that a deal
that cancels student debt and restarted
payments would reduce inflation taken
together the actions the president
announced today are not only
economically responsible they will
provide real benefits to families so we
look at the other independent experts
this is uh this is also something to
take into account as we talk about
inflationary causes
i'm gonna stay on the student loans
american students pay higher fees
in comparison to western democracies by
far thousands of dollars most of us in
western european countries subsidize
college fees so why can't the
administration negotiate with banks who
makes billions of dollars in profit to
make sure that student and loans are
interest free or subsidized i mean most
of us who are parents can barely send
one or two kids to college in america
look the president himself put three
kids through college undergrad and
graduate school so he understands the
burden of what
of what having student debt could mean
for for a family for individual which is
why he took this action look we see this
action that we took today is going to be
beneficial it's going to help families
we went through the numbers that 90
percent of families that it's going to
help out that's making less than 75 000
uh
you know a year that matters that is a
big percentage of folks that are going
to get relief and so this is one
approach that we're taking we've taken
the president has taken other approach
historic uh approaches when you look at
again the 32 billion dollars that he was
able to cancel
that debt for 1.6
million borrowers that matters we've not
seen that when you think about uh the
historical uh black colleges and
universities who he has historically
[Music]
invested provided six billion dollars no
other
president has done that amount before so
look the president is going to look is
going to continue to look for ways
to help out middle class americans to
continue to look at ways to help out the
people in communities that are left
behind
but what we're going to focus on right
now is on this particular
announcement that we're made we are
encouraging
we're encouraging americans out there
folks out there borrowers to take
advantage of this
and to see if they're eligible and
that's going to just be our focus for
this time
okay all right thank you guys we'll see
you
to be tomorrow to raid the home of the
top political opponents
you